breaking news the founder of wikileaks
julian assange
is finding out if he'll be extradited to
the united states
he's accused of blocking plotting to
hack computers to obtain and disclose
national defense information our crime
correspondent martin brunt is at the old
bayley martin what's happening
well julian assange has just been told
good news
by the judge uh who has said that she
has disagreed with the american
application to have him extradited she
has ruled that there will be
no extradition and she said she has
ordered his discharge
the the americans of course have
a right to appeal so i guess it's going
to be some time
uh before we hear what the american
reaction is going to be
but she the judge vanessa
barresta has said in the last few
minutes that she has decided
that julian assange's extradition to
america
on espionage charges 17 of them would be
oppressive that news
doesn't seem to have filtered out to the
dozens of
assange supporters outside the old
bailey in the last few minutes they've
still been shouting for his freedom
now whether he is to be free today
is a moot point the judge started giving
her reasons
for her decision just after 10 o'clock
and has waited
until the end of that explanation before
announcing
that decision but i'm just being told
from a
colleague in court that lawyers will be
coming back
at a quarter to 12 so in about 45
minutes
to prepare a bail application so there
is that it's
distinct possibility uh that after
uh so many uh 21 months in custody at
belmarsh prison
seven years uh inside the ecuadorian
embassy
uh where julian assange fled to avoid
extradition to sweden the original
extradition bid um that he could be
walking out
of the old bailey today um but yet that
has to be decided
and of course we wait to hear to see
whether the american government
will lodge an appeal uh against
his let's just remind ourselves of
julian assange's status at the moment
um he was of course uh originally
uh sought for extradition to sweden
on sex-related charges those uh have now
lapsed uh he's been serving a sentence
in the uk courts for um jumping bail and
going into the ecuadorian
embassy uh is that sentence now
uh expired and it's just a question of
whether he's
extradited to the uk or becomes a free
man
yes that um that sentence of 50 weeks he
was given
for jumping bale after his arrest uh
at the end of uh that uh that time in
the ecuadorian embassy
has finished that was may last year so
that sentence
has um has been completed sorry
may 2019
so that sentence has been completed it
was
shortly after he was given that sentence
for jumping bail that the americans
filed 17 espionage charges
against him which meant that at the end
of that sentence
he had his bail rejected while this
extradition process
was played out the 17 files
sorry the 17 charges filed by the
americans
accuse him of receiving and publishing
classified military
and diplomatic documents
um among which of course was video of
uh the alleged shooting by american
troops from a helicopter of iraqi
civilians
a lot of what he published and there
were thousands and thousands
of documents published via wikileaks
were connected with u.s government
actions
during the iraq war and the afghanistan
war
the indictment that led to this
extradition hearing
accused julian assange of repeatedly
encouraging sources
with access to classified information to
steal and provide it
to wikileaks to disclose now all of that
has been rejected by the district judge
vanessa varesta she has
ruled in the last few minutes there will
be no extradition
but as i said earlier it's now open to
the american government
to appeal against that decision
and we should hear within the hour
certainly any uh application by
assange's lawyers for his bail but i
think we might have some indication
from the american government whether it
is going to
appeal against this decision but the
judge here
has ruled out extradition saying it
would be
oppressive on julian assange for him to
be extradited and stand trial in the
united states